welcome everyone to Entertainment
Tonight Kevin Frazier's off we begin
once again with Gwyneth Paltrow of her
ski accident Civil Trial and more from
gwyneth's big victory in court
was Gwyneth Paltrow at fault no
Whispering I wish you well to Terry
Sanderson which one meme jokes is
Brentwood for bless your heart Gwyneth
triumphantly sauntered out of the Court
after her one dollar win her exact words
I wish you well very kind to her I said
thank you dear was this worth it
absolutely not I'm going to be on the
internet forever I wish you well today
in hell
despite being a viral sensation Gwyneth
says it was worth it for her because
quote I felt that acquiescing to a false
claim compromised my Integrity Mr
Sanderson categorically hit me on that
ski slope and that is the truth for one
of the eight jurors it all came down to
the Oscar Winner's credibility wait did
I have a unanimous decision she's always
it was also a Victoria 's day in court
for Meghan Markle a Florida judge
dismissed the 75 thousand dollar
defamation lawsuit filed by estranged
half-sister Samantha Markle
she accused Megan of making demonstrably
false and malicious statements during
her Oprah interview I grew up as an only
child she changed her last name back to
Markle only when I started dating Harry
so I think that says enough the judge
said The Duchess was expressing quote an
opinion about her childhood which was
not capable of being proved false
meanwhile Prince Harry is still waiting
to learn the fate of his breach of
privacy lawsuit against the publisher of
the Daily Mail
Harry felt the love yesterday after the
final day of preliminary hearings
however there still seems to be no love
lost between the prince and his father
according to a report the two never saw
each other because King Charles was
quote too busy
[Music]